hello everybody my name is Nyan I'm the
black female engineer I provide content
for you and aspiring software engineers
and today we're talking about
the best team to work on because like
that's not something I ever thought
about considering when I was
transitioning into this space but now
that I am a year in and have the ability
to think of okay where do I want my
career to go and what kind of teams do I
like working on especially now that I'm
on a different team now it's like okay
these are the things I've noticed these
are the things that I like the most I
like the least and I want to share that
all
with y'all okay
now I started off working at Dreamworks
Animation Studios a lot of you will know
that already and I worked on the
production engineering team this team
worked on tools that were solely
internally facing what does that mean
an internal facing app system process
tool is a tool that will never see the
light of day it will never see y'all an
average consumer a the public it'll
never see any of y'all instead it will
be seen by those within the company and
even sometimes then it's not seen by
everyone in the company but just a small
subset of people so my team worked on
developing tools for artists for
managers for people who were making and
editing the movies and making sure that
all the colors were the right vibrancy
and the sound matched with the the
characters lips because again they are
cartoons they are not just people
walking around in this Earth so that
means other than the small subset of
people no one was seeing the tools we
were making now I'm working on a team
under Xfinity I'm working on the Xfinity
team that works on building iOS
streaming apps for Xfinity for those who
don't know Xfinity oh I should have done
that for DreamWorks as well DreamWorks
is an animation studio one of the
biggest in the world like movies like
Shrek Shrek 2 Shrek 3 I'm I love Shrek
so those are the ones I those are the
ones I uh share most
um when I talk about or when I had
spoken about working at DreamWorks fun
little game real quick okay y'all what's
better Shrek one or strike two we're not
even a try with Shrek 3 and Shrek
Forever After that that was one also
right there were four strategies Shrek
one or Shrek two y'all like I'm curious
put in the comments let's let's start a
war but yes that streamers Xfinity is
also a team under Comcast that works on
cable services internet services mobile
streaming services like what I am
working on now although it's only been a
couple of weeks it's been like what five
weeks working on this team I can already
spot some differences between this team
and my other team so my other the team
as I said internal facing tools and
whatnot this team the things they've
built and developed the hope is it does
reach y'all the hope is it gets out to
the public and so that creates a couple
different things there's definitely a
heightened sense of urgency with each
task because of it because deadlines
matter way more now before with
DreamWorks with my other team deadlines
yeah they mattered ah I don't know even
that is a stretch for like my specific
team because I remember it was like
month two or three and I was assigned a
buddy on the team please please please
if you're on a new team no matter how
old you are get a team buddy somebody
who is around the same it would be nice
if they're the same age as you bezeline
is like this the same level as you
because that means it's not long ago
that they experienced or were like in
your shoes get a buddy loved my buddy
she had been working Frameworks for
about a year a year and a half by the
time I came on and she was like yeah my
age and everything so it was phenomenal
went to my buddy and I was like girl
like
I like don't have much to do day by day
like I have things to do but like
not much
and she was like oh yeah that's how we
do things here and I was like what and
she was like yeah I know especially
since the pandemic the attitude around
here is you'll get it when you get it
like as a software engineer I get a
certain assignment I hear that you have
a certain bug you'll get the fix when
you get it like we are not saving lives
here we're making cartoons why are we
stressing out about this we we make
cartoons but now and this is like not a
bad thing at all know that nothing I'm
saying is a bad thing now I definitely
see the urgency uh in things this entire
week my team has been like running all
over the place they have been trying to
get things together get things
um ready for deadlines and presentations
and everything because how long things
take directly affect the customer the
consumer the public experience with our
tools and the public is a lot less
forgiving and patient uh here to Mia the
manager at DreamWorks using virtual you
know and so things are just so much more
like a go go however some advantages of
being at a team that produces external
facing products
are one it can be a lot more exciting it
can be so exciting working on a tool
knowing or feeling or with with the
possibility that it's going to be seen
by y'all I can say like hey guys if you
download this app this very popular app
and like go to this tab that page there
I created that or that feature that you
liked I created that I remember I saw
this Tick Tock of the guy who created
the undo button on Gmail and he was like
that was me y'all and it's so cool being
able to say like that's me who's making
a difference in your customer in your
consumer experience
his eye that you've been waiting for and
that's so so so exciting and fun and the
possibility of that can definitely drive
people and so that's for sure for sure
one benefit of being at a team like this
another benefit is these will likely
stay pretty interesting when things are
constantly changing because consumers
needs are changing and adapting and
evolving and you and your team have to
rise up to the occasion that can be
pretty fun it doesn't need to be this
terrible experience this daunting scary
thing it can be fun being like Oh okay
like consumers are challenging me to
like rise to this level like okay Bet
and Still I Rise you know that can be
really really exciting because when
you're on an internal facing team it can
kind of get to this place where it's
like ah if it works it works like we
don't care as much about it being super
pretty or being super exciting it's like
if it works it works tell us if it
breaks but even if it breaks like don't
tell us
you know you know and so that can
definitely be the difference between
those two now having your things out
there for the world to see can be super
exciting
however however something you need to
think about is the flip side of that
because you are working on a team that
is producing public products
what happens when that product breaks
do y'all remember when Facebook and all
the 30 000 things they owned broke for
like it was a while too it was for like
hours it broke can you imagine what
being a software engineer for those
teams were during those days during that
those hours
no no no no no no no
don't sign me up for that don't don't
sign me up for that if something breaks
at three in the morning somebody needs
to get up and fix that code we can't
wait for Monday at nine just because
that's when typical working hours are we
can't wait for the weekends to end
somebody somebody needs to get up out of
church take out their laptop and fix
this and likely that's the work of
back-end developers of these types of
teams and that is not something I ever
I'm not back in developer but still like
that's something to very much consider
and the reason this situation really
not I'm not gonna say only but typically
exists with the public side the external
side rather than the internal side is
because the products we're working on
are only going to be touched by other
employees when they're doing their job
why are you logging in
at 3am on a Saturday
go to sleep like why are you logging in
right now and so
ideally we no one would even know that
something is broken until 9am Monday
morning and even if someone found out
something was broken during the weekend
let's say somebody need to catch up on
something and they found out something
was broken they will relay their
findings to the proper team and then
we'll go to bed they will not and should
not in my opinion expect for for a fix
to be addressed immediately and so
because of that a life work balance is
so much more achievable and attainable
and sustained in a team that's more
internal facing again it still also
depends on the role you have if you are
working let's say front end for an
external facing tool even if something
breaks it's less likely that you're the
one who has to wake up to fix it so
there's so many nuances to this but
overall as a
very anxious and I don't know software
engineer who
gets stressed quite easily
um I very much appreciate internal
facing teams I do I love it that is home
and shoot I'll be bored like I will
figure out something to do to occupy my
time
um and that doesn't mean that I'm not
working by the way like it could mean
that I'm putting time towards my own
professional development I'm putting
time towards learning more languages
learning more Frameworks going to Tech
conferences so I can become a better
professional I have the time and ability
to do that because I'm in a less
demanding space as a person in their
early career I really just also love
that ability and that space and time to
grow at my own pace rather than growing
feeling like the world is on fire that's
not fun for me so yeah there is what I
think is the best team an intro facing
team and the next time you're going
through the job hunt ask these questions
ask what specific tools you'd be working
on ask if those tools are interested or
external ask what the process is what
the operation is for addressing bug
fixes and things breaking and who
exactly is expected to address these
things in what order let me know what
other things you would like to discuss
what topics what questions what like
Observer like let's just chat you know I
really that's going to be my tagline
from now on for the challenge like let's
just chat and so thank you so much for
chatting with me and I'm so excited to
see y'all back next week bye y'all